[Musik]
das nimmt mich einfach mal manchmal
komplett mit wisst ihr das ist gar nicht
so einfach
sowas 15 minuten oder 20 minuten
ertragen zu müssen
ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie
das es ist einfach traurig hey was geht
ab jetzt willkommen beim neuen video ja
jetzt lange drauf gewartet ich glaube
die letzte folge bzw
die erste folge davon ist schon so
ungefähr drei wochen her und zwar gibt
es heute endlich eine zweite folge von
musicals zum fremdschämen aller alex wie
ich bin nicht unter ich gestern doch
einige komplimente bekommen habe dass
mir so ein ding steht habe ich gedacht
kommt warum nicht so macht es einfach
noch mal leute bevor wir allerdings mit
dem heutigen video anfangen wollte schon
mal kurze sache ansprechen die wir im
letzten video passiert ist was mir im
endeffekt mega light und bzw
ich weiß nicht ob's stimmt aber warum
sollte man es einfach zu sagen und zwar
hab ich im video ich glaube es war so
kurz vorm ende sogar da war halt ein
musical von seinem jungen wo ich gesagt
habe
wo ist der scheiße weil das war total
synchron mit der tonspur also es hat gar
keinen sinn so gemacht so wie er seinen
mund bewegt hat und wie er seine hände
bewegte und so und ich hab dann oft in
den kommentaren gelesen dass der junge
top sturm ist und das gar nicht hört so
aber da habe ich mir auch gedacht so
woher soll ich das wissen sorry so das
wusst ich halt nicht als wenn ich das
wirklich von vornherein gewusst dann
hätte ich natürlich nicht darauf so
reagiert wie ich reagiert habe
und ja da wollte einfach mal kurz zu
sagen tut mir leid das wusste ich nicht
normalerweise alt als wenn ich sonst so
was sagen würde so dass der ball
schlecht ist oder so ihr wisst was meine
also noch mal sorry an die da irgendwie
gedacht haben hey was dann mit dem muss
ich wusste es ehrlich nicht und jetzt
können wir auch mit dem heutigen video
anfangen also es geht heute musicals zum
fremdschämen paar 2 und heute habe ich
mir vorgenommen mich ein bisschen weiter
zurück zu halten und nicht vielleicht
jedes jede kreatur oder wie man das
nennen möchte direkt so anzugehen
ich habe mich zwar ähnlich aber ich
kenne sie versuchen aber bei manchen da
kann man sich einfach nicht zurückhalten
irgendwas schlechtes zu sagen weil es
einfach scheiße ist es natürlich wenn es
durch gefällt und ihnen auch im dritten
part haben wollt dann lasst auf jeden
fall genau jetzt schon einen daumen nach
oben da und ich würde sagen beide sagen
wir 13.000 likes gibt's dann auch den
dritten park ich bin mir sicher dass
knacken war okay ich bin bereit ich
hoffe ihr seid es auch letzte was ich
dann kurz mal anmerken muss ich glaube
ich schätze mal die wahlen gesagt 11 ich
wusste mit elf ehrlich doch gar nicht
ich war da doch gar nicht so aufgeklärt
das ist ja heutzutage schon echt ich sag
mal so das ist ja ist eigentlich nicht
nur negativ weil ich meine dann wird
wahrscheinlich weniger 13-jährige geben
die schwanger sind
weil die jugend einfach schon viel eher
aufgeklärt ist wir machen einfach mal
weiter
nein
die tage die sie ist ich hoffe jetzt
einfach mal das ist kein alkoholisches
getränk war weil ich meinen die rechts
die am ende so ihren bh hochgezogen hat
war vielleicht 14 und ihre kleine
schwester war neun höchstens und ist
auch im internet
da haben die eltern auf jeden fall da
muss man applaudieren
[Musik]
heute weiß ich mich gerade zu fragen ich
denke jetzt mal ihre mama hat sie zu
ihrer freundin gefahren oder so im auto
wenn jetzt meine tochter so neben mir
sitzen würde
und irgendwie sowas aufnehmen würde von
wegen männer legten intesa und da war
dann irgendwann auch so machen würde
würde ich mich auch fragen ehrlich ich
würde sofort wieder mit dem auto umdreht
und erstmals drei wochen hausarrest oder
nicht
[Musik]
wieder so eine im internet und die leute
die impuls muss sich auch fragen was
macht
[Musik]
da die
man macht hat er irgendwie ich so hat
gesagt kopf viel festgeklebt wacker kann
man kann doch ganz normal geradeaus
gucken oder nicht wie sieht das aus wenn
ich so in die kamera gucken dummkopf
alter das gleich hab ich mich gefragt
als dieses fragezeichen da rein kamen
wer denkt sich so auch einfach so er hat
auch eine kasse boxershort die ist von
der marke e dur
[Musik]
jungs zieht euch doch was an
es gibt t shirts sie wurden erfunden ich
glaub schon sofort ist auf jeden fall
schon ein bisschen her schon wieder
[Musik]
das ist echt eine gute frage wer filmt
das bitte ich mein okay die eltern
würden für mich jetzt schon mal
rausfallen wird dass sein bester freund
aufnehmen wäre vielleicht auch etwas
komisch am nächsten leider noch seine
freunde nun da frage ich mich auch
kann man doch nicht so toll findet
freunde oder naja
[Musik]
da frage ich mich auch wieder warum ich
glaube da hat gerade seine ersten
milchzähne hier vorne verloren aber kann
am perfekten zone durchschnitten
[Musik]
das nimmt mich einfach mal manchmal
komplett mit wisst ihr das ist gar nicht
so einfach
sowas 15 minuten oder 20 minuten
ertragen zu müssen
ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie
das es ist einfach traurig
[Musik]
na ja ich möchte jetzt auch gar nicht
weiter aufregen ich würde sagen alex
erzählt wunsch du hast es mal wieder
geschafft du hast einen neuen teil
zustande bekommen dankeschön dafür auf
jeden fall was auf jeden fall ich
wiederhole es gerne ich finde die app so
an sich finde ich geil ich habe dir auch
selber zusammen mit meiner freundin wenn
ihr uns sondern nicht folgt dann macht
es auf jeden fall war einmal aufs alex
ist ihr kurs einbindet checkt es ab und
was wir auch mega freut das geht einfach
gerade weil ich nicht ich mache auf
youtube zwar immer noch meine neuen abos
sag ich mal aber musical geht komplett
durch die decke und das freut mich
megawatt wirklich spaß macht das ist was
neues das gibt's doch nicht so lange und
dafür wird
dafür wollte ich einfach mal kurz danke
sagen danke dass sie uns so aktiv
verfolgt sag mal ich kann ja einfach mal
kurz den werte liefern uns an machen und
den euch zeigen und unser ziel ist es da
irgendwelche kreativen sachen halt also
ein bisschen kreativ zu sein oder
lustige sachen zu kriegen und nicht sich
auszuziehen und zu sagen ich bin geil
und wird jede pussy lecken oder sowie
das dieser ich gucke jetzt einfach mal
wie machbar den an
das war es auch schon einfach fünf
sekunden 4 sekunden und einfach mal kurz
irgendwelchen leuten die uns erfolgen so
ein leichtes lächeln vielleicht
verpassen
man muss sich doch nicht ausziehen oder
sehe ich das falsch könnt ihr gerne in
die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr meist da muss man sich
ausziehen das ist geil dann kurz einsatz
wenn ich sagen ich hoffe dass wir
deutlich gefallen und es hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten falls ja wie gesagt
teil drei stürze ich stürze ich mich
dann auf jeden fall auch noch drauf wenn
das video was hat immer gesagt 13.000
genauer 13.000 locker easy drin denke
ich mal genauso der chat ist haben wir
auch noch beides eingeblendet was sie an
thomas schulz jetzt erwähnen würde und
zwar ich würde meine facebook-seite
gerne wieder so ein bisschen auf pushen
sag ich mal oder halter generell was
passt deswegen wenn ihr facebook hat
ständig es mega cool wenn er einfach mal
auf den ersten link oben in der video
beschreibung blicken würde und meine
facebook-seite licon würde das war echt
voll da und merke ich auch gar nicht
sagen wir sehen uns dann morgen beim
neuen video
jetzt kommen wir gesagt sehr sehr oft
videos fast täglich und alex wie army in
die comments schreibe ich auch noch nie
gesagt und alle die mich für dieses
shirt hätten weil dazu viele risse drin
sind ich konnte einfach aussehen